the Internet is going crazy you're
seeing it firsthand this transformation
Oh Salma Hayek's reaction to Camille nan
Jionni's body is all of us I've been
saying it from the beginning but you
know there's like a moment of he goes to
the gym and I'm like oh stop it just
like stop humiliating people you know
because you don't want to go to the gym
I don't want to go to the gym and it
just makes you feel bad the 53 year old
actress is starring in Marvel's new
flick the Eternals alongside of bulked
up Camille and Angelina Jolie oh my god
they're so they're they're so amazing
it's such a diverse cast you know just
our backgrounds and ages also in
personalities and it's incredible how
this director picked these people that
are so different that can bond together
so well and we're going through a
journey that is very intense and you get
a family feeling because it's it might
continue for many many years and we're
really proud of what we're seeing that
it's happening with a movie and that's
also another way of bonding together et
spoke with Salma while at the premiere
of her new comedy like a boss in my
experience be sness and friendship don't
always mix you don't have to wear your
pretty over here my head is not little
it's just that my breasts are humongous
the actress dished on why the cast
couldn't stop laughing on set we find it
very fast was right it-- we were very
tired at some times the entire makes you
get the giggles easier and we really
really really
we really enjoy each other we really
enjoyed it we enjoyed playing the
characters but I really got the sense
that we enjoy watching other people play
and by the way I remember a couple of
scenes because Jennifer cooling and I
love her and she has a different style
and the rest you know she talked I
remember there were a couple of takes
where I was just like staring at her
because she was improvising the most
bizarre stuff who was just want to
follow and I would forget that I was
acting and then I had to actually say
something so she was the most
distracting to me but it was it was a
lot of fun I kept like yeah and we've
seen a lot of improvised line you do it
once the way was scripted and then yeah
but I think it Jennifer they wouldn't
even let her say the lines just like go
up they stopped that was coming out of
that mouth was so naughty
most of it they couldn't even put it in
the r-rated movie
[Music]